you just asked me if I'm ready to do
this podcast I'll explain something did
you have your attitude again well well I
got an accent I wore this that's why I
wear this denim jacket to piss you off
now I wanted to take you to cut those
sleeves off as slam bought it - bro let
me ask you a question
well no noggin zoo resident I just wanna
warn you that I have a lot of energy my
Energy's coming back because I I don't
drink or dairy or cyber worry everyone's
well aware of that well doc you might
have died hey I was little uh III my
wife goes uh what's going on with you
and I go what I'm fine she goes you're
very irritable I go no I'm not
she goes when you stop she looked at me
she goes you've never done this before
but when you stop all sugar and dairy
and all that stuff things are gonna
happen to you oh yeah withdrawals hello
I called you i text you yeah I felt I
was feeling very very irritable from our
last podcast no it was just I was before
that in the morning you know I was like
what the [ __ ] am i annoyed about it's
real man it's real right oh yeah sugar
dairy cuz I stopped cold turkey I didn't
do it never do you know what I realized
that I've always eaten healthy I never
went a day without ever a day without no
sugar I always had something right oh
yeah chocolate or something or whatever
was and then I I never had gone a day
without some dairy I never had gone a
day without and Moute were rarely do I
go to bed and not have a glass of wine
or to glad he went cold turkey call
turkey that that was very interesting it
was like you know you think you're nice
or no usually takes about seven days no
no I'm still still still prickly I'm
still prickly like I still wanna I still
want to fight you still want to start a
racist Club the nepalese day yeah yeah
well right when you cut sugar you get a
little more racist you hear the or
ambient whichever one you mean
you're gonna get it's gonna be a week
where you could ruin your entire career
science bro
it's just science mascots are gay and
when you cut sugar and science man
you're gonna get a little bit racist how
was uh how was last night at the Euro
Comedy Store I mean at the improv
well uh it was interesting because when
I got up on stage there were some of the
best-looking women I've ever seen in my
life
that's the improv it was crazy rose yeah
and great-looking guys like a bunch of
young beautiful it was like the it was
like the young casting couch it was like
actors models and just just young
athletic guys oh what a good meeting in
clumps it was a mating room as I meet
Nash hmm and and it was just it was just
and they were all and here comes the old
guy and I felt but it was fun I did my
thing but felt they were young and they
had when young people like that they
have their whole life ahead of them like
they have dream library when you're
good-looking Artie Lange used to say I
hope my children are dumb and
good-looking because if you're dumb and
you're good-looking
life is great because you don't
overthink [ __ ] to get laid and the world
everyone's up the world your oysters
right if you're ugly you gotta work if
you're ugly yeah you got to develop all
the other aspects you lice you have just
been everything you've earned man that's
right you've never been handsome correct
just kidding
well you're you're you're [ __ ] up
you're a good-looking guy you were
varsity blues but you have something
else going on I don't know I don't know
either it's good though I'm battling
gayness well you have a lot of secrets
for sure but either way it's important
and I'm glad I bought this denim jacket
and Houston jegos don't worry that don't
wear that in stage you went way is just
please don't you like this it's Texas
man it is Texas is don't you really you
don't look like anyone else here I'm
like I know I never looked like you no
one else you and I light you'd be fine
it's this is Houston please don't wear
that with your own shoes pleat I'm just
and I was like damn you theaters he goes
I'm serious
wow I was like all right won't you get
away with it with your it because you
got the Erie away with in LA yeah right
rest the world divider though that's all
right mmm I mean I know you mean yeah
rest world's pretty I don't I don't
appreciate it now sometimes I do it just
to piss you off I know you got yellow
socks the great shoes but they carry
minute these these TAF denims
little Taff denim boots they sprayed
that denim jacket some glimmer warp
before me
painter vibrant paint you guys can try
this right there there are little pink
splashes of pain
oh dude I appeared on an episode of dear
double dare I don't know
Brendon or Doubleday yeah I do old
school I just feel like that I don't
know man
yeah it's great Congrats thanks bro
I had a audition yesterday and I thought
would that type of character wear this
and then I liked what you wore for the
audition
pretty pretty authentic right tell us
about the research tell us that was a
Brennan had an audition I can just give
you a broad strokes you had to play Navi
a large a large Mexican gangbanger
correct okay yeah and apparently they
thought I was suspended as well and they
would be forgiven for it because you
couldn't look more Chris panic when I
told my wouldn't do it oh wow okay you
told them that no I didn't look okay
yeah so you went and you did your
audition did they have bait you do it
several times three times three times
three times what would the directions
what they say um well I came in make him
laugh which when you're playing a badass
skin kind of yeah but she like I came in
and she was like you're this guy's funny
well you're nervous and so you're tryna
but I every room I go into her I never
just walk you like is it go time like I
was I you know that's a really people
does a really tricky things I used to do
I come in and I would make them laugh
and then um that's a serious role I had
an act I had I had a casting director
said when you're coming in for a role
like this she said don't be a cheeky
actor and I went what do you mean she
goes you come in and charm the room it's
not very helpful to you because we want
to see the character yeah and I was like
[ __ ] so like just like this is my thing
like I only know how to do that yes I
must be myself yes so if you go don't do
that like now you're wrong I want the
role it's not life or death and I'll see
you're like you're like in there yeah I
don't like that kid because for two
reason this or that then I'm just not
the guy yeah so if you're gonna shut me
down for that but are you always saying
what left I'll tell you what I told him
to I went right so I did I had the three
of them laughing or whatever yeah no all
right let me get serious yeah let me
play this serious cartel member now yeah
so what I would do I used to do at all
the time it's very common yeah now what
I do is I go like this I go how you
doing
here cool and I go so real quickly I
just want one question about this guy
now is he and I would ask the question
like the character like I kind of ask
them a question and and so immediately
just to get myself relaxed yeah and they
make a connection
yeah but I'm but I don't know longer
joke and yes start then and let me play
this guy I just go well I also had a
note too because there's this scene that
I'm doing super intense and you know
he's getting kind of bullied and I've
had that happen in Brazil the exact same
situation because they wanted me to
react this I go I wouldn't react and
they go pretty sure I want Dom to if
I've been there I wouldn't react it's
like a lie and I used your reference or
there's like a line in the room I'm not
gonna move I don't move I'm frozen I'm
not gonna do [ __ ]
also if he's that small he's not pushing
me back what you guys want try pushing
me back try so hard you can't with your
finger poop post push me in the chest
see what happens I'm not gonna move try
it and they're like that makes sense
it's how you say yeah good for you I
went I've been in I have I've been in
that situation so that this is this is
real life this how are you backed I said
I'm sure if you had guys come in here
and they're like all over the place no
no no as big as I am try pushing me see
what happens he doesn't move and see
good for you I love that yeah that that
I'm already intrigued oh I don't know
house - I don't know house - fake that
well I'm already intrigued with that
yeah because don't get it twisted you're
still a gangster and you're still tough
right now he's still a big tough dude
him smaller guys doing that to him it's
he's not gonna any still around you know
tough guys in the room he's not gonna
back down to that yeah
it's also he's not gonna work yeah
that's interesting I love that's the way
that was my take on it I love that that
that Morgan Freeman they say did that
when he had to play a pimp and he came
up and they want him to be really
menacing and all I did was he came up to
the casting director and he just moved
her hair out of her eyes he casually
just moved a hair on her ass and he said
yeah you're gonna do that - uh-huh and
the [ __ ] look at the producer goes
have you done this before are you a pimp
yes you know and he got the part little
ears sometimes it's doing those little
tiny things right it's like my teeth
McEntee jeffrey tambor said that he goes
the scariest thing was when I was at a
diner and I asked the guy what he did if
you're playing a psycho you know this
guy was like hey can we stop the scene
oh geez I don't know you're doing hey
he's all sweaty like I ran he's like oh
what are you planning as well he's crazy
he goes mmm crazy that's not scary
because I see it because I'll tell you
scary he was having he was in New York
and at a diner he sees the guy and he
goes um what are you doing Jeffrey goes
I'm an actor and he goes oh oh great man
I've always want to be a knife that's
awesome what are you doing is not doing
anything right now but I'm planning on
killing the president
so the very experience go together sub
down the street yeah play I kill the
president anyways how are you Jordan
Peterson in his book said when he deals
with paranoid schizophrenics paranoid
schizophrenics are not dumb and they are
and they're also but they also feel
slighted like they're very upset and
they will get you like in their mind
they're not they're gonna get you back
so if you're at the DMV and you're an
[ __ ] they become your worst nightmare
Jesus because but they're rational in
their own mind so so when he treats
talks to a paranoid schizophrenic he
never lies to them he never lies he's
very honest with them because if they
feel slighted they're coming up well
also like they know the difference
between the truth and he'll say you know
you're speaking like this the guy go
like I'm gonna go in there and kill all
of them or any because you're really
scaring me this is scary and I and I'm
gonna be honest with you they don't
realize how scary it is well so he goes
this is not gonna work out for you know
this is that not a good plan and I hear
what you're saying and obviously you're
somebody who means what they say Jesus
but but but so even dealing with
somebody who would be a paranoid
schizophrenic who's somebody with label
crazy wherever you can't lie to them you
still have to tell you have to be you
tell them to kill you yeah dude speaking
of crazy [ __ ] how about on my way to
downtown today at my studio there's the
worst traffic I've ever seen in my quat
dumb never late I'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on and the five was shut down
and I look over and there's 30 cop cars
underneath the bridge and this huge
balloon like pads
someone's gonna jump on commit suicide
yeah I mean they said was a protester
though who's threatening to he's
protesting with an also threatening
suicide so they literally just shut the
whole five down I was like oh my god and
I didn't want my my team I was three
minutes late even with that was three
minutes I have never been late and I was
so disappointed I know I'm telling you
this something's going on with the five
there's a SWAT team out on what the
[ __ ] going on they blew up the bridge
or maybe they're filming Expendables 19
and they shut the five down but
something's going on
go look and they turn on the news and
sure enough first time I did Boston I
was really late to my show cuz of that
the poor guy was up on the thing and
they had to shut down and we were
waiting protesters blocked Freeman flash
or year listen let's San Diego snow let
be the same well we got we had now now
that that ruling that Trump said people
from predominately Muslim countries and
Venezuela and North Korea which is how I
got around it so so they had they were
like here they build the bin yeah
because they added those two countries
that was sneaky so no you know if you're
from North Korea or Venezuela you're not
allowed to come as well and those are
not predominately Muslim so we got alert
we get around that band so the Supreme
Court was like you can't say it's it's a
bigoted even though they knew dude how
about it do you know that I referenced
that show before hunting Isis on here
were those guys who are out of the
military go back to Syria and Iraq and
all over to fight for with the curse
even though they're not American
fighters so they fight with the Kurds
right so yeah so with the Kurds are
fighting the one dude on there from
Arvada young kid this last episode died
and I was like what the [ __ ] I couldn't
believe it yeah he like stepped on ie D
on accident I believe the [ __ ] up that's
what's correct
that's called a war zone yeah that's
called a war zone they come in after
though like a lot of them you know the
the official military goes in does their
work and then those guys comin after
like look for Isis where they're at or
for a reason I I when I wasn't all those
guys who were doing it they're crazy so
the one main guy who has the most
experience and he actually trains the
Kurds to help him with their tactics and
shooting he he left he went back home
found out the kid died and they're at
home they're just drinking and doing
like they have nothing to do they like I
have no reason to be in a
like it sucks for me man so they all go
back they'll go right back because they
have no cause I know cuz I'll see you
get addicted to that kind of thing I
when I was there and of course I
remember seeing um I was in the hospital
I saw two kids and I won't go into what
it was but I just kind of was like and
then you see other people and it's so
it's so um it's so real man it's so
[ __ ] real that stuff well when it's
so Rios guys taught when when those guys
talk and they go you know why are you
here doing this you're not getting paid
for it you know and he goes because I've
seen what Isis does to people babies
children women if I see what they do
it's the worst things you can imagine
and there go and these all these guys go
I won't stand for it it's like you I'm
over here to do something they're
badasses yeah and you get it like [ __ ] I
get it
so they go over there I gotta watch this
they go over there and they say $2
burger they say the burger I want to
fight with you guys
yes and then they have to be smuggled in
otherwise you know they're [ __ ] they so
have to be smuggled in somehow I would
not allow them to go it's not attractive
ya have to be smuggled in Wow
and then if they get caught they get
arrested or they get terrible but also
these guys are talking about all the
foreigners where they're Sweden these
are just American no there's some
Swedish guys they follow most Americans
one swedish guy the americans go you
know there's been guys come over here
they get caught by isis and it's the
worst thing that could happen do you
like you get caught because everyone's
told if you get caught just to try and
kill you really get to you my buddy i
told you my buddy who was up in that
area he would carry a so what kind of
weapons do you carry and then the last
thing i was there and i carried like you
know it's the pistol in case in case
because well i mean you can't get you
cannot get captured by no it's game
cannot get captured and they show
sometimes i'll shoot yourself they show
a lot something like more than you would
think especially for have iceland show
well it's on national TV like they show
some of the stuff if when they catch
americans i mean it's in so really
intense
you're like dimming cages and they light
on fire it shows for americans hanging
and then they set the ground on fire
beneath them so the hosts it's like the
worst [ __ ] you can think of
yeah human beings have always figured
out ways but they when I was hanging out
with my boys in Texas well you know
former spa that was just like literally
that the creme de la creme you got Delta
guys seal 20 they said I asked my girl
were you out on Trump man like where you
guys feeling it was a great conversation
starter buddy - we had on that and they
go the way they go we don't again
specifics when it comes to trunk but in
politics that's whatever they don't but
what we will say is before when Obama
was there he never released the hounds
on Isis so they're staying around he
goes when Trump came in he didn't give a
[ __ ] and he released the hounds and goes
we dismantled them within two months Wow
and I and I went I said but did Obama do
that cuz you would kill a lot of
innocent people and he goes they he just
went it was but Trump has at zero he was
we got to get rid of him by any means
and say he goes and then they released
the hounds and we took you they call it
they call it let slip the dogs of war
let they let slip the hounds of war I
think it's less if the the hounds of
hell the two did so so Circe's where is
the dog that the three-headed hound that
guards the gates to hell and and but
they but the but the Shakespearean so
much of what we talk about comes from
Shakespeare which is let ya service
versus Cerberus the three-headed dog but
so much of yeah the Hound of Hades but
so much of it is from Shakespeare let
slip the dogs of war and when when after
9/11 they asked standard.i McCain what
do we do and he said let slip the dogs
of war and he goes one Trump came when
you do that when you let the milk came
in and well go get them boys and the one
you hear those guys I get chills talk
about wasn't it you and you hear them
talking about you like [ __ ] we are such
badass well well yeah it's none bad no
no no no no like I felt so American out
there yeah when you like fell I felt
like like I always had a bubble but I
felt like grabbing one like damn you
know it's been that way for how long
when you let the when you let the might
of the of the American military machine
work the way bro ons we all have the
drinker brothers on this proton this
podcast because one of them it was in
charge of all communications and
breaking it down the way it works and
when he goes also we take the poor too
and he starts out and then bring
Special Forces yeah and when he started
breaking my organization oh [ __ ] you
yeah and then this is what we do next
and then we bring in these Navy SEALs
then we bring in these Marines you bring
in this army these Rangers and they're
breaking all down goes on then the air
control Mike Watts out [ __ ] yes oh yeah
oh yeah yeah you're not any ghosts Trump
released that you're not doing [ __ ] with
your ak-47 and your thing I feel like
such a gun in the large the question is
the larger question for the military and
for our foreign policy is is to what
extent does killing and annihilating the
enemy totally to what extent does that
create a bigger problem so with that but
that would be the other they went on to
say how you know they think Europe's
gonna be a real problem with all the the
Syrians well you want to win the war of
ideas - and you want to win hearts and
minds so that so that the the idea Isis
doesn't become an idea that gets into
people but that's what it is yeah well
that's that's why the lone shooters in
the launch right that's extremists there
that's been brown before then yeah
there's a way to win that war too though
because I think like and so well in
world war ii world war ii think about
this world war ii and people talk about
this all time there was the concept of
total annihilation of the enemy i mean
the number of people we killed in tokyo
in an 8 day period the number of people
of course we killed in hiroshima and
nagasaki with the tuna bombs the number
of people were killed in dresden dresden
looked like the surface of the Moon so
did many parts of Germany and so Russia
we absolutely won Russia was Russia
people don't know this badly they served
20 million that's more than anyway yeah
the donor brings it up and then oh I'm
more after that under Stalin and with
the red purge but Russia's suffered so
horrific Lee it's beyond imagination but
but yeah you're you're right and but I
do think that there's a difference in
that there was total annihilation of the
enemy but we rebuilt Europe under the
Marshall Plan we rebuilt for the most
part Japan the aggressors in the war but
I think people realize that we were on
the side of you know we were on the side
of democracy and we were against fascism
etc so there's there was a lot of that
too so it's a question of it's a
question of are you morally consistent
and and what are you leaving behind when
you do this and all that stuff it's
really complicated
it's really complicated we just have to
be careful that we're a country that's
great not because just because we have
incredible lethality with the biggest
guns we're a great country also because
we're a beacon of hope and an example
and that's why I worry about this this
Muslim ban and all this stuff that's
from that word I'm worried that we're
getting away don't [ __ ] around
don't [ __ ] around it's exactly what my
favorites quote from World War two when
they attacked Pearl Harbor and the
[ __ ] I think it was general Togo
someone who had who had been the one -
or it wasn't him it was the guy who led
the squadron the guy and they said it is
the mission accomplished and he said
yeah yes but he had studied in Tokyo I
mean in Detroit he said yes but you have
awoken a sleeping giant and now you are
in trouble
hey and that's what I'm Erica correct
um yeah moving on how about you kario
part two comes out I can't wait I think
Thursday
that looks bad this Friday for me to go
to movies Abby's absolute Tiger and
stuff like that so I'm going up Friday
night again [ __ ] mate I got an idea
make it all legal make it all legal and
see what happens to the crime spend a
lot of money on finding there's a lot of
money in fact you see Sicario won-jin
know the posters they're doing whoever
came the news on that cos that one and
the have you seen the billboards on LA
with the scholar all right yeah this is
such a good I mean it's not a cartel
member I would get that tattoo on my
back oh [ __ ]
that's a double you know I get that
tattoo all American flag that'd be sick
my son that's you know I might put it on
him
how about this more time we'll pack and
it was a goddamn [ __ ] Fiesta the shop
household because the you know Mexico
played in the World Cup and had to tie
or get a score goal and depending what
happened with Germany in South Korea for
them to advance so they ended up losing
but they scored a goal and Germany got
their ass whooped by Korea to nothing
because nothing Mexico moves on of
course they were holy he worked on me or
stay pulled Brazil next
well they showed me a picture of yeah
that's what all these Mexicans will grab
the
grin off the street and they were
holding him up there going because Korea
wants a new neck skin the soccer my
household weight Mexico's gonna play
Brazil next there they moved on the
plane bridge how good is Brazil's team
though
excuse me some say the best that are
assembled is that true yes here yes okay
they're the highest most likely to win
now and was them in Germany but a peat
precio do Mexican it's it's another
they've routing harder they excel a
small earthquake when Mexico scored do
you know that Mexico City no it's
brought the same ratio as Earth Day oh I
want to see some Mexican panel there's
nothing better Ching no that sambar
store I think it's on their Instagram of
when England they're in a pub I'm gonna
post this because the England plays
tomorrow that's my [ __ ] squad and
hopefully I real Mexico is my team well
I know but if you go to a bar stool
there's a picture of them in a pop and
off seem XR England beat the [ __ ] out
the last team six to one I think keep
going
but it shows these dudes in a pub and it
is insane yeah British fans how much
fans so keep going
there it is far left yeah watch this
so it says England goal celebrations are
another level hit that is their volume
yeah
you ready
[Applause]
how great does that laughs Jesus Christ
listen the music that's just a random
pub in England but they are [ __ ] they
say the British come alive in war and in
football you know that that's the same
the Brits come alive when it when it
comes to war and football how great is
that look at that [ __ ] right now go in
there with it with like a different
Jersey from another country see what
happened wonder where it's going they're
wearing a germany jersey you get punched
in the face so easily right there how
great is that the makes you want to go
oh yeah I get my England Mexico I'm sure
it's the same [ __ ] Oh Mexico go [ __ ]
crazy I want to see it oh let's see that
I just want to see them go for a good
holy
we're not freaked out Brazil's gonna be
a dude they if they win I'm getting the
Mexican flag I think you might walk into
it bro again I met I might got my
English jurors come in number 9 cane you
do I get Tiger jerseys give that I came
down this morning and the whole family
if they don't get me a Mexico Jersey the
whole family's in green her brothers
they're like hey that's cool I like it
Tiger Nia's his little Jersey on cutest
[ __ ] I'm like oh if I can get him
English Jersey do you mean what's taken
extra-large and men's double X yeah like
sir kids SS it's gonna be a house he
likes it though wrister thicker than
mine
you know what we signed up for sake
starts playing soccer in September
that's awesome that's really good I
guess I'd let him play football if he
has a gift for it Alan please do you see
that Washington State quarterback no I
read it to the sign the kid he commits
suicide they checked his brain he had
the brain of a 65 year that's what I
heard I was gonna ask you about I just I
have to say that the more evidence it
comes out but that's the exception in it
he's a quarterback he's not even a
[ __ ] and let's affect oh you know
he's probably taking a lot I don't know
what his high school playing days were
like I have no idea you didn't bring
that up chance we can see it Washington
Station watch State quarterback commit
suicide bomber I see but I don't know
what his earlier plane did what did he
run an option high school was you run
the option offense what was he doing
because if he's just a drop at
quarterback do you have the shittiest
offense line of all
time but you know in this guy off so I'm
defending football here but I really
think a lot of the CT stuff and within
fighting to but a lot of its that you're
the exception when you see these
horrible things I think there's a lot of
problems with it but there's a lot more
guys exception yeah I think there's a
lot more guys walking around who are
fine mmm
I bet if you looked at the numbers I oh
they might have knee problems neck
primary you out and the reason I say
that is because meaning well I think
that you're right because overall see it
is true it is true the CTS or real thing
it is true the CT affects a lot of
football shares but there are a shitload
of retired football players who are
walking around and they are fine well a
lot of a lot more if they're not fine if
they're not fine they they're not
showing signs but also and a lot of them
are freaking killing it I mean Michael
Strahan if there's a scruffy feet so Bo
can't destroy him or how about Frank
Gifford how long did you monitor was a
very high level till Sims Troy Aikman
yeah some of the more worst concussions
you've ever seen Rex and Jerry Rice is
pretty [ __ ] sharp Deion Sanders
Michael Irvin's one the most smart
articulate men you will ever move it's
just there's a liar ease doesn't it and
go to the actual articles I talked to I
talked to Bo Camp Bow caman played on
Miami for 10 years defensive end and
played forever and I said do you find
any he's 65 he's got 50 restaurants is
he killing it and Mary ferns Albert oh
yeah long did I have and he goes no
specific what is a do you how do you
feel anything cuz I don't he said I said
what about your friends he goes honestly
all my friends are fine i I don't we
haven't had any so so so you're right I
think it affects various it depends also
it says his parents joined today this
morning Hinkle's father said Medical
Examiner's told him tell had the brain
of a 65 year old which is really hard to
take and then they asked it football
killed Tyler and he says I don't think
so
his mother told sports analyst read did
he get CT from football probably was
that the only thing that contributed his
death I don't know look we know suicide
affects people a lot of people who never
played football right
so you
can't blame it on football but see I
think this kit and I think this happens
a lot with celebrities and a [ __ ] like
you know when people go Kate Spade had a
horrible depression let's say she's not
blue state and she also had a drink
improv right well I don't think she has
a drinking problem because she had
horrible depression if they might go
hand in hand
but she had mental the reason she
committed suicide was not because she's
an alcoholic it's because their mental
illness was she sad since she was a kid
or maybe she was drinking alcohol
because she didn't do fill the void
right
so she's trying to fill a void but the
the root of the problems are mental
right you had a biscuit it says people
need to keep - oh well her mom said his
mom says people need to keep talking
about suicide mental illness and mental
health we need to erase the stigma
there's not enough out there these
beautiful athletes that give themselves
to their colleges but their minds aren't
taken care of
look it's it's it's a mystery isn't it
isn't it a mystery we still don't know
fully but we know that maybe maybe in
some cases this does play a role
maybe CTE I think this is the perfect
storm I think he had a mental illness
where he had bad depression he's hitting
a head a lot maybe that tipped him ride
over to then you would get suicide but
also we also I think that kid would been
depressed with his playing football not
mark Gordon who who is was on Rogen's
podcast who deals with helps a lot of
soldiers with their depression a lot of
times it is true medically that
apparently if you if you get brain
trauma your testosterone and your sex
hormones sure will go completely haywire
grow your hormones will drop your
testosterone everything and all that
stuff and that can that can have an
effect gonna have to we also know yeah
so so a lot of that stuff can be the
fact the real bummer though they only
see that [ __ ] yeah but I I do think it's
interesting that you say that about like
there are a lot of football we know that
there are a lot of you if you take their
overall numbers of football players that
are still alive today and are doing just
fine and they're they're contributing
society I'd say the odds are that the
the numbers are with that look again
look Edie how long did you play football
on did you fight for us I played
football since I was what four and then
I fought after that for seven years okay
sheriff punches to the face sure the
[ __ ] did well-documented yeah so now
you're not you think you're looking at
me right now you're looking over here
Bob Silva
wait where am I yeah yeah why am I
dressed like this that's whose dick did
I so that's a question whose dick did I
oh [ __ ] it's the CTE dude
are you out tonight I'm Takami Stone
improv I'm not you know I could come out
though they're gonna loose spend some
time I've been really enjoying my kids
dude I felt so bad I supposed to do Josh
Wolf's show last night is this new show
and he had Puma sent me some special
sneakers and they had this shirt this
David Bowie shirt cuz like sponsor
sponsor show depend on the guest but
then my Edition got poked pushed back by
an hour till 5:30 and then his show yeah
be at 6:30 it's in [ __ ] by the Kodak
Theatre which is hey Josh we keep closer
too far in the mill rush hour I was like
dude I just I just looked at this I
wouldn't get there for another two hours
I felt so bad man and now it shows off
the arrogance just kidding what's the
show I forget but it's he's killing it
man I love Josh yeah he's the best
what a bummer about Tyler Olinsky what a
[ __ ] tragedy for his family
that is a yeah it is a Josh wolf show uh
well he had the Josh wolf show which was
on CMT but this is he does on Facebook
oh just some big guest on good his
podcast is good too if you go to his
Instagram sure it's on there cuz it's
around I'm sure you could find out here
to check okay any social media platform
[Music]
are the next fights
mm-my the next big fight steep a meme
and yeah we'll break down next week as
he gets closer it's just normal with
Josh wolf
let's finish calling the show normal
yeah I mean I know I was rapping fairly
normal yeah you know I'm not sure chin
his only show man I would go to just his
uh it's kind of you Nashville nope
that's not it
I know couldn't it just go to his his
regular face we can scroll down you'll
see the show they both
Jen I was there doesn't matter
yeah and it's over you missed the hype
finger it's over meaning is I'm over it
it's not there keep going down keep
going down a pot you see a posters show
him a bunch of people on the couch they
keep going there you go there it is
last night's episode of chaos with Josh
chaos with strife is the best one yet
there you go there you [ __ ] go Brad
Williams Jeremiah oh there's a kid a
mile walk heaven that our boy Kevin who
Stefan on him Brian yeah that's Kevin
yep you talking about the guy who
created [ __ ] yeah that's not him yeah
it is no that's racist that's not that's
not Kevin
no what's his last name Kevin Smith nope
definitely not me that's not Kevin Smith
on hold please
that's like Kevin Smith I've seen
Kenneth lately yep yes Clay Matthews
he's not his hair
Kevin's lost a lot of weight Kevin Smith
[ __ ] right he did he had a heart
attack
yeah nice beginning well that'll do it -
I'll do it maybe you need a little more
scare like your lights trying to give
you a little heads up I'm the red
spotted leopard dude you're the red owl
you've the big red game no I'm there on
the spotted owl I'm just I'm the red
spot
I'm ready pop you're 51 you know thank
you my psoriasis I'm I'm the spotted red
red spots
what has red spots in the wild Oh
reverse no no I got to be a I'd like the
spotted leopard something like the red
the red leopard no no that sounds too
cool what has red spots red spots what
kind of animals rats you're dead red
spots I don't know man
well red spotted animal I'm sure there's
some fish outside Spisak what writer
springer spaniel dogs have large spotted
knew it sometimes you will be a new
potential I said I knew how much you the
big gay new
what is that what do you mean they're
lizards they're like wet lizard oh yeah
I used to have a lute there's a there's
a [ __ ] uh you're right you said frogs
yeah that's a that's one of those
poisonous frogs poisonous tree frog I'm
a Panama Frog yeah the Panama I'm a man
frog
the man from I'm the man man frog
pandemonium a hug man frog from Panama
yeah you ladies like a 51 year old with
two kids a wife and red spots on his
body kid it called me the psoriasis kid
do you that's a weird-looking ladybug
first I'll tell you what you don't do my
son goes to this summer camp place and
they have all the whole thing where kids
can stick their hands in with the
ladybugs and leave except their hands
well there too and what they do is when
you do that go ah
[Laughter]
uh-uh
when they brought our I feel like that's
a bad idea with these kids because it's
gonna took on my son's hand and those
big old mitts that he has probably just
shut pretty tight and hard than I know
most kids just the real gentle they're
like I don't think so some little boy
goes just knocks them off like all of
them fall out and I'm like oh this thing
you me good man my son's like ah I tell
you about the guy who I knew who I
you're like your friends or somebody and
you go they do something and you go oh
you're a closet serial killer looked at
him different guy in college we were 18
and this there was a hamster cage and
the hamster had babies and there were
all these little pink babies and the guy
I got this is so [ __ ] yeah you get
these meds if he goes he goes I had the
the sink was dirty and there was a one
of those like that he put one of the
babies no no no he's God and I was like
knowing you happy before I knew what it
is before I but I didn't I did not I
thought he was just being weird and
funny and now as I think back on it I
was like as you learned more yes [ __ ]
yeah you wanted to feed a little bit
answer into our [ __ ] you know and I
we were 18 base you ever going to come
on dude come
Chinni don't let you know having disease
or anything does any viral not being
random encodes the addiction to creme
you're an STD no he's not gonna admit it
he doesn't Alan I would have missed a
private man I'm pretty honest about
stuff oh you're not I thought you guys
denied my eyes you guys know what I'm
sorry yes or no so well we all trust
each other here the plans on the fourth
chin yeah what are you doing on my
friend Jeanette usually has a huge 4th
of July party where's the difference in
you and I didn't go far I don't have any
friends named Jeanette don't have any
real friends I call girls unless they're
because they're married to my friends so
then they're my friends but really my
friend even though she's mad yeah or
will there be fireworks illegal
fireworks illegal yeah every year dude I
be racist agents had the best firework
yeah if I fart you guys make him do you
know why because they make them and
smoked lemon you know where gunpowder
was yeah there's no restrictions either
out there like all the Disneyland
fireworks agent you know where gunpowder
was invented China
that's right [ __ ] stupid knows who
took it and then put it and said let's
put this behind a ball of metal the
English yeah yeah let's shoot that at
somebody's face and guns were born yeah
then you could kill at a distance and
that's why the Sam who died the samurai
[ __ ] when we have their guy they were
like you know a [ __ ] we've all seen
last words and bows and arrows but I'm
gonna shoot you with these these guns no
dude time to educate all oh that's right
and you know what may do you know what
here's a what did make remember when
people were wearing come on hold on hold
on this is it Borden knighthood remember
when people were wearing like in they
were wearing like armored Knights and
you had to learn how to fight in armor
and you had to be big and strong and
[ __ ] like that so you were covered in
metal and you fought guess what [ __ ]
guess would turn that into a [ __ ]
coffin right quick and it wasn't guns
what invention rendered knighthood
obsolete overnight made it up made a
mockery of it no matter how strong that
metal was what was like oh yeah
and what became so that metal was your
biggest friend liar
nope and then it turned into your
biggest liability because you were slow
and you were just sitting there horses
the crossbow mmm the invention of the
crossbow speaking of horses though what
was the biggest what was the biggest
advantage in warfare when it came to
horse gear saddle yes I was I was gonna
say saddle close the stirrups cuz you
could you could sit up on your saddle
and and steady yourself and shoot a bow
yeah little details like that is crazy
yeah the shape of Europe change and he
gave me some fight we shut the [ __ ] up
for summer Jim we get some firecrackers
if you guys want no you're not gonna
where do you get them they make me
nervous
yeah really told but you know what he's
the biggest puss in the world
firecrackers like they're like
Disneyland they should marinate blow my
dog's freak out so that's what I don't
like either don't show your dog's dying
no no he was oh this is great this is
[ __ ] this vet is a genius
so my dog gets his balls nipped cuz he's
been trying to fight large dogs and
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of the Corgi
uh-huh he thinks he's the baddest guy in
the planet yeah so my buddy Ryan who
trains dogs is awesome he said listen
did your dogs awesome but he's a problem
because he's trying to fight my police
dogs so long story and I love this talk
so I I [ __ ] he's running and he's got
a cone cuz he got his balls Ned he's got
crazy energy and one day he goes like
the cone got in the way and he kind of
like he stepped out and he cried and I
was like I'll [ __ ] so I took the car off
anyway next day this [ __ ] is
down I mean down and then the next day
he's down next days down three four days
later I'm like this guy's not getting up
he's just gave about four days well he
was eating I nobody wore day well I kept
expecting to get better cuz ya know I
taken the doctor cuz something's wrong
I gave him a doctor the doctor checks
him checks his lymph nodes listens to
his heart and he just looks at me he
goes let me guess goes brian succour you
let's put him down no clothes he goes he
checks under his stomach and my dad was
like that he goes and watch he touches
his stomach is
I think he pulled his back and I go
excuse me
you guys pull this back I go yeah but
you're touching his stomach goes yeah
stomach is not the one the muscles come
down so when I touch the back extends
and he goes up and he goes and touches
one area the back like that is I pulled
his back freak accident
I go I I remember it because he stepped
on the call and that's when I hold his
head down and he put any screams we get
yeah nothing bad so I pad back so I goes
look I'm gonna give you some muscle
relaxers and sure enough did the help
one day a muscle relaxers my dogs like
his yee-ha [ __ ] that vandals core ace
to blow their bats I didn't either he
said a lot of long dogs can do that like
you've never those and wiener dogs have
bet yes now I want you to I want to get
your take on this if you don't mind I
don't know if you know this but when you
know horses are big money right I don't
know if you know you agree you can pay a
you can pay a adjuster I'm coming in to
adjust your horses back and I want to
get your take on this because you're an
athlete it's 1,200 pound horse and I saw
it and the chiropractor comes in and
they push hard on the back the horse and
get it aligned black magic take it away
how much did that car that'll cost you
hundreds and hundreds of dollars like
God what would you say on that I mean I
mean if it was the big race were side by
any means this thing is doing [ __ ] thank
you but it feels like one of those big
like thanks for questioning it my wife
really uooo uooo snake oh I'm sorry
snake oil I'm sorry I've had a lot of
people talking about chiropractors for I
mean legit be like it's really not like
if it feels good for you do it because
then your sleep affects me as far as
does it really do much for you actual
that your body alignment no look I'd
done I went to many chiropractors and
that I that I was with Lauren Landau and
a guy named Leo flowers both who really
study sports physiology I mean look you
work with elephant leo yeah no you own
the same Lauren decided class by himself
yeah Lord Lauren's lighting coach with
the dead yeah and I did the exercise why
spend one day with Lauren he brought me
in to in Denver and Cody was there I
spent my back was [ __ ] I spent one day
with him where
me a couple of exercise rocker I'm going
to show you and I'm telling you right
now that I never had a lower back
problem again because I'm at what I like
when the chiropractor's cracked my neck
but then like I get immediate relief and
then right want to get my car like
alright I'm nervous about it some lady
died from it yeah obviously that's the
exception
yeah have you seen a chiropractor chin I
did you still do no I did before I give
you these exercises I want I want you to
tell you see any of that stuff chin it
was for a car accident and I think they
just wanted to make money so they just
put me on a like a retainer for you like
vibrating visible therapists like who
study that those are the guys yeah you
know and also people swear by
chiropractors of this that's your thing
if you'll better do it man but there are
you stand out the bodies in line too and
they can give you exercises and all like
there's a chiropractor said is your ear
aligned with your shoulder I can solve a
lot of your problems right now you know
align your Europe with your shoulder
let's start there you don't have to go
come getting adjusted let's start with
your alignment yeah made it be different
you're some kind of engine yes sir first
one is Joe Jackson who's Michael
Jackson's dad the Jackson family dad he
passed away at 89 years old in a long
time dad took a lot of heat when he was
alive
mm-hmm said he was pretty rough on those
kids yep created a money superstars
right yeah that's the question what he
died from pancreatic cancer mmm I'll
take it you bear next to the Sun or I
don't know who never had a stroke in
three heart attacks yeah 89 good run
though
it's very good running I'm at that coat
over here in that picture what does get
chin
alright what you guys are already
talking about Korea winning over Germany
and online there's just so many
different things going on with Mexicans
and Koreans and Mexicans thinking
Koreans for winning look like it's huge
and here's someone like this here same
answer similar culturally and
lightweight very similar yeah super
super close their families loyal to turn
tough hard-working yep
was just I'll show you this is a random
cream guy I love this [ __ ]
I love the World Cup Mexican fans saw
some random green guy and then they just
grabbed him lifted him up like you the
hero yeah see him on the shoulders
there's one there's a bigger monster
than furious right now right now this is
an older Korean dude Mexican fans just
lifting them up they're just random
Koreans at these watching they're all
you're welcome you're welcome
it's so cool to see become of our house
gentle how my son lifts you up yeah yeah
who's the other ass would Jimmy get
their ass whipped by Korea which is
shocking
so input I mean Korean barbecue tonight
wow thank you guys
everyone what's the best Korean
restaurant in Korea town for cramp I
love Korean barbecue so I have to I'm
sorry
top three yeah I think I guess she cough
Jong which I'm sure you guys heard about
before to know that left a Yelp kana
dong Baek Jong and quarters are they all
downtown they're all like pretty much in
the same area it's a place called
Chapman Plaza or on there see if I try
it I'd like to go to the best yeah I was
hoping you guys would actually go cuz
you haven't even been there yeah I've
never been a Korean I love it it's it's
so freakin healthy it's just meat and
vegetables and the fermented vegetables
like to try it I love it I love I've
never been doing it this Friday you're
welcome where both of you
I'm doing it with tailpiece with Hunter
mots and Brian over a hill who's right
in the new Batman series for marvel
smartest [ __ ] guy with his wife and I
don't know but it's gonna be a fun table
and we're gonna take Korean barbecue
yeah what do you I'd like to do chin
what I don't go with a bunch of YP well
there's that place waru on we should we
should actually go [ __ ] and fast omit we
should go and film it the one I wore oh
is not good would waru
so I can't do it and you put on your
chin Kim yeah I mean I was just film
like his it'll be a very first time
doing it if you cool the capture Jason
because he loves ya we I want with him
in Koreatown in New York I think he said
it was one of the most delicious things
he's a good Korea Korean in Dallas why
do I think that I've had great Quran bar
there's a lot of Korean places in Dallas
yeah because there's a good chunk of
Karina's there I'm gonna doubt I want to
go to I want to go to the ones in
Koreatown
me too I think they're better dude - I'm
[ __ ] sure
depends because you guys have was really
good like I've have eaten there it yeah
[ __ ] good
I need Chin's approval on that I got to
try it I got to try war I've eaten a lot
of Korean barbecue with Koreans mm-hmm
you know in New York and in DC and stuff
like that I don't know if you notice but
my kicks are not a joke sorry but anyway
yeah so that Joe alright in Korea food
today longer tip your honor I just said
I say well doctor you know what that
means close it well go ahead let me shut
the [ __ ] up let me just close your mouth
I speak Korean yeah I now say oh that's
good mostly hopefully the Koreans know
why Mexicans are running after him give
him hugs oh they know come on they're
they're freaking are now to it Korea
beaten Germany I know but still that's a
good that's the best way to go on if
you're not gonna make it
you helped I agree you know my puckett
it says Mexico soccer fans vowed to
start listening to kpop father
six-foot-five and and super-sweet and
that like really like a real really
liberal guy and gets really mad at the
injustice world it was Christmastime
news
we're going down we're driving down to
skid row and we're gonna hand out money
oh so she gets out and he sees the guy
and he goes hey it's huge and he's got
long bro hey hey and the guy sees him
and he goes oh hey and he's got monies
running after
the guy [ __ ] runs and runs into a
sign and then hits and it gets all
starts to scream it was not well you I'm
trying to give you money goes get away
from me like there like that get back in
the body arm and it didn't work it
didn't work that's funny
Skid Row I mean drive through it now no
I have it is terrifying
yeah it's so low there's so many people
who are mentally definitely super close
what are you do they remind me of
zombies I'm not even kidding it's true
they seem like they're in their own
little largest encampment of homeless
people I think in the country right
[ __ ] crazy it would make sense just a
few spots in LA yeah what else you got
Jim alright well here's one more for
this once one this is another random
Korean dude where people were taking
pictures of them just Mexican fans
taking pictures of them Koreans getting
their dicks Ike they're not guys he's
right there in the middle just embarr on
[Applause]
it's cool to see that right that unity
you're pretty crunk about it I'm super
crunk about it yeah yeah I mean whatever
about it yeah well that's because you'll
see if England wind got a killjoy keep
going alright so this is a team looking
they're good play tomorrow they should
move on I'm sure you heard of the
sorority that the Anthony Joshua fight
with Wilder seems to be off because he
has to fight the W a is making him fight
Povetkin it's off and I'm gonna sit down
interview with wild or tomorrow so he's
talking about it and then your boy
[ __ ] Eddie Hearns came after me on
social media Oh yep what do you why
what'd he say ah because I you know when
I say my sources my sources are Showtime
and [ __ ]
Deontay Wilder so when I saw it was in
that Joshua was taking another fight
against Povetkin
I went hey here's what's going on while
there agreed to all the terms and you
know Joshua's team decided to go a
different direction that's the truth
now you heard and got on there start
talking [ __ ] who's hurting he says Eddie
Hearn is the promoter these drops rose
in the world and he was not true and all
this stuff and then I go not from my
source this is what I
you guys needed fifty mil Elterwater
guarantee fifty mil you guys won UK
Deontay Wilder agreed to UK and then you
guys renege Don the on the deal and then
send back another deal that was just
pure [ __ ] which no one would ever agree
to cuz they take a lot out yeah that's
what's going on here mmm well so so what
is the advantage in fighting providing
Povetkin why wouldn't they fight the
wilder are they afraid of why we don't
know we don't know what's going on who
is Povetkin Povetkin oh he's a
heavyweight champion so he's you know
who'd be another it's a mandatory
defence for anthing Josh I knew I
smelled [ __ ] but Dan Jannsen Joshua I
didn't know that moto is that strong you
carried eyes [ __ ] had the world waiting
for three months playing games just for
this moment you're not a true champion
you're just a weak-minded coward that's
holding hard metal facts
damn that's Dante Walters you don't want
to come to my defense because that hurts
like who's your source and then D
underwater came [ __ ] flying off the
top like what and then what not thought
of nice and now me and Dante are sitting
down tomorrow that's all good III do so
what do you think do you think it's
actually I think he said he heard I
think he said he heard his fault I look
empty and Josh is not afraid of Deontay
Wilder bothers not afraid of anthe
Joshua and he Hearn listen there's three
people you know trust in this world
Santa Claus that work at the mall guys
that drive vans and promoters you never
listen to them ever you never talk to
them yeah so when Eddie Hearn says
something it of course he's gonna make
it seem like Beyonce Waters [ __ ] and
all this stuff
I bet Anthea has no idea what's going on
I thought maybe her take care of this
he's hoping he's like alright whatever
you think's best man and they're telling
this is best cuz there's some motive in
it Freddy Hearn he's launching some new
thing no you eat he sends over a
contract that's not complete that no one
would ever sign for a reason it's shifty
stuff you can't trust promoters so when
you guys defend promoters when you
defend Dana White or you get it you know
how many times has he lied to you and he
hurts lying there's there's anti Joshua
what he thinks there's [ __ ] Dionne
Sawada what he thinks and there's some
middle ground where they need to meet to
make this fight happen but Eddie her and
always has different agendas the
promoters do
Dana white you think is it you think he
has the same agenda for what
best for you know the promoters there's
a reason why Brian Stann Tim Kennedy
Kenny Florian Michael Bisping great guys
don't become promoters because you got
to be a slimeball to do it you have to
have some sort of dark side to do it
those guys you don't think Brian Stann
would be the best thing that ever
happened to the UFC if he took ship the
reins of that or Tim Kennedy's offered
they were they both offered position no
people wanted them to but they would
never do it because they're not slime
balls yeah you have to have a dark dark
you have to have the darkness we take
advantage of people to become a promoter
there's a reason why you gravitate
towards being a promoter it's not
because you're the most thoughtful
nicest sincere you know sharpest dude in
the room it's because you can't fight
and you get into it somehow with Eddie
her and his father handing over the
business what Dana White he had two rich
friends there's a lot of common kind of
practices with all these promoters
they're all the same Don King themes Don
King named a fighter he likes Don King
talked to Mike Tyson about Don King and
you get many years went by and they just
did a speaking engagement and Mike Tyson
that know Don King was gonna be there
and then outs Don King used to touch
Mike Tyson my testicles don't [ __ ]
touch me I want to Center all these
years why do you think why do you think
no one likes these guys because they've
all been [ __ ] over I'm King the motors
never ever do what I think any horns
doing what's best friend to Joshua he's
doing what's best Freddie Hearns brand
does anthe Josh only has one more fight
with him any promoter you've ever heard
leaked this Mike Tyson's not playing you
just don't touch me [ __ ] Wow
again like he does say that don't touch
me [ __ ]
looks pissed off hmm
you think he [ __ ] him out of a lot of
money man mercy did you cheat him a lot
of money she did of course you did you
know when the hell if it turns on the
trainer you know and circuses that's all
this that's going on yeah but is that
that that's a James Jermaine Taylor
right there right that's Antonio Tarver
okay um so you know right now you know
Mike Tyson I need him for anything you
know Anthony Joshua needs that he heard
for some so you don't hear a nasty job
your auntie just would speak he's
getting us all second hey I've talked to
Wayne McCall and he talked did you talk
to yeah but we were tell you these guys
you're talking big big money yeah like
Wayne was a smaller guy your time
life-changing yeah but the same
experience yeah it getting dirty [ __ ]
man
these guys join tens of millions of
dollars Mike Tyson target hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah so of course
when he was touch they [ __ ] off and
now you know promoters are gonna promote
that's what they are they're gonna do it
maybe we need unique Don King is a I
mean I don't think anybody would ever
deny that he's through and through a bad
[ __ ] guy they're all like that
they're all the same
all of them are the exact same every
English teach you ever had they're the
exact same energy right all promoters
the exact [ __ ] thing there's a reason
why you're drawn to that profession we
need them but know what you're signing
up for yeah
people love strippers you don't marry I
know what you're signing up for it you
know I'm saying yeah
so will so we'll see what Delta I'm Dion
to alder see I think he's more
disappoint than anything because he
wants to make the fight have music I
don't understand man I don't know you
think I literally I don't understand
it's one of those things we're all dying
to see it and then the only the only
problem is is that he heard well a team
here we go you don't know the facts of
that he had he said whatever Edie's
telling you it's gonna paint him in the
best light possible he's great at his
job Grady hunts been great for boxing
with their promoters so whatever he says
it's whatever man yeah you can't take
that as that's God's word that's that's
that's that's it that's the truth
because he's painting and what I was
doing when I was telling what's the save
drama to enter water British up so when
I was 10
what deionta water can't do this one's
telling him I go what you can't do is
let Eddie her and paint this narrative
you can't let that promoter make it look
like you're the one that back that's
right
and I'm telling you guys that is not I I
work for Showtime I know the details of
this contract and on the fight so it's
it's not that gentle I was like nope not
sign it I need this in this I promise
you guys that's not what's going on here
it's not I believe you I black eye so I
just want the fight I like anything Josh
was one of my favorite fighters Jen - I
don't I don't I'm not biased I don't
give it I just want the fight happen
I'll give a [ __ ] who's right first I
just want the fight - hello so my
feeling is that Eddie Hearn is not as
confident that his superstar that he
makes a lot of money off fans named
Joshua can beat Deontay Wilder so maybe
he wants to maybe he wants to stall for
time what is it no he's launching some
new thing right who knows either way
it's no good that's by the way what
you're saying is is it's it's in Eddie
Hearns interest to do this it's always
in this interest and Povetkin is not an
easy fight when people go when I ought
to Walter you know he needs to merge the
Bell - he needs to unify the belts with
the [ __ ] up with that well to unify
those belts he has to fight Anthony
Joshua what the [ __ ] are you talking
about right and he's waiting yeah we'll
see I'm suing the interviews gonna be
intense there's really not time though
because Povetkin is a tough tough fight
for him and then Wilders gonna fight
Brazil if any one those guys lose you're
out man this whole this is over then we
got many Pacquiao fully admitted where
they're all over again
got Lennox Lewis you know yet brick beau
that's what we're dealing it's a real
shame man and why because you got greedy
miller men with no talent in the middle
they want money that's right it's the
same it's the same story over and over
Hritik beau is not afraid of Lennox
Lennox afraid Riddick
waters not afraid of any followed any of
the because that when I was going to do
Kevin and bean I did Kevin bean and they
had they're gonna have Dana on the next
day and one of the things they're gonna
talk about it was that the UFC's ratings
I believe our profits ratings ratings
right now fifty five percent which is
pretty
to a disaster hmm and they were gonna
ask him about it now I don't know if and
I think that a lot of what we talked
about which is you have these
up-and-coming stars and you throw them
to the walls so early that's not it that
you that you don't create that's not it
that's only that's I think that's only
if you're bald so what
so did he go on Kevin but what's this F
I don't know what he said but I'm really
not going to him be he did go on Kevin
Dean I don't know what they asked him I
doubt it I think they did ask about Doug
tell me think we're gonna ask him into
the in front of them or he looks at the
question goes that ain't happenin okay
there's no way you should see ball that
and I be interested to see that Kim and
B Dana White yeah is it 55% I I mean
just but no no I'm dead specific just
but I I want to see what he says because
um just put Kevin bean yeah was it
recent yeah
that's all yes this was literally he
should have been last Wednesday or
something last yeah she had been a week
ago let me look at their engines you
know I did who is responsible for that
and no one everyone what it's their
business plan I think they have a lot of
great fighters not effective more you
know they're more loaded with talent
than they've ever been before but they
don't have that you know without Rhonda
or Brock or you know freaking uh Conor
McGregor you don't have those huge you
know pop culture streaming numbers or
pay-per-view numbers so you know but as
far as talent wise they're stacked man
it's it's a it's more of a product of an
old business model which is pay-per-view
you have all these all this free content
these days you know so whether you're
paying for you know whatever DirecTV
Dish Network Comcast's and they're
paying for streaming service Netflix
Hulu and then we're gonna ask you with
this paper new motto to [ __ ] pay
another $60 a month to watch fights I
think it's just people like now the
World Cups on or the NBA Finals were on
or then if the playoffs are on or
I can go see a live performance I think
there's too much free content out there
to charge $60 to watch this now right
unless it's unless you have a huge star
and that that you know that that's this
they're bad business model I think it's
an old school business model I think you
know and also there's a legal streaming
now yeah but you know very well about
you're talking about every UFC like dude
I don't know the link I'm like dude come
I don't know what that you're talking
but the illegal streaming I think she
changes game to because kids ought be
kids my age kids younger go pay $60 I
would also like why would I do that 95 a
legal link right here I'm just going to
click that i watch of mine they don't
give a [ __ ] but they could and also
y'all remember they know the UFC is
[ __ ] over the fighter the other thing
so the really cold up finals I've seen a
[ __ ] time of this we're not hurting
them you know well when I buy the
pay-per-view on my iPad I better be
watching it I can't record it I have to
be watching it live you can't you can't
record it for later on so that's another
problem well and it's still 65 is
actually 95 bucks for me at one point no
no something crazy they have never 95 I
don't know there were two high if I do
it's either it's either the 54 95 or
69.95 anything for HD or something like
that yeah that's what I got or 59.95 or
HD yeah but either way and they increase
the price so I again I just go talk to
you
holdout 91 box pay-per-view HD Plus fit
yourself six month UFC fight pass what
are you getting that's a special meal so
originally it's $4.99 yeah but that's
the strategy that's they're trying to
hang on to fight past cuz their vs pm+
coming out which you got to pay even
more money for so I just think
especially with 18 to 20 sales Boxford I
just think 18 24 year old males are like
wait I'll just illegally string this
[ __ ] if I am into it most time I don't
think I think I'd imagine the numbers
are down for younger audience hmm
there's just too much good content out
there man yeah
but it's a shame you know I want them to
do well and the big fights are still
doing well they seem you shouldn't see
how UFC 226 does yeah that's gonna be a
big big one to tell but like DC steep a
they've never been like huge draws
unless they're facing you know much
bigger name max Holloway Brian Ortega
they've never been big pay-per-view
stars France is in Ghana not a big paper
you start black piece so when people
think this thing do over 800 I don't
think so
well they're member when they were
talking about who's a movie star and who
is who can open them loses back in like
2000 and the list is so small when you
actually ask when you look at numbers
and you look at actors who are actual
draws not people to star in movie Oh
like Leo DiCaprio very few my god you
couldn't believe how few for example
back then this is 19 this is 2000 I
think and they were like the guy this is
a big producer a big-time executive at
Warner Brothers me and they're like well
there's Morgan Freeman he goes he goes
hold it because Morgan Freeman is not a
movie star as in doesn't more movie star
you to bring people a theater we often
see we're like I was like whoa whoa what
don't say that he goes knows not I feel
like that and they gave me the list and
it was so small super small and I was
like holy [ __ ] he's in and I'm going
yeah yeah like who's in that second
that's so so even for acting like if you
look at the numbers if you look at the
people who are actual draws you all want
great actors in your movies and there
are people who like movies like you have
fight fans that will go see who knew a
Brian's hair Ortega isn't like me I
can't wait to that fight but if you look
at the large numbers there are very few
draws also I hate to tell you like this
if you if you've been balls even you see
as long as I have and we've been fans in
here you look at this card and was it
dude it's stacked it's like yeah it's
alright trust me I've seen way better
yeah like it the two fights that I think
are really intriguing our steep a
Cormier Holloway Ortega well no [ __ ]
that's it but I mean everything else
there's no [ __ ] well no I'm saying but
the other ones it's not like you'll see
200 which that card sucked or you know
you'll see two times I'm saying
they're not stat yeah who's saying this
is a stat car most people think like
this there are two five I did think so
too but now you're talking about drawing
power it's true
I don't say that's why I'm saying you
talking about draw power like steep a
yeah Francis you know steep a he's never
been Ibiza and it has nothing to do with
his skills you the greatest heavyweight
champion of all time but he's never been
a huge draw DC he's only a draw when
he's fighting john jones his fight with
Gus Finn was not great numbers-wise
that's Holloway Brian Ortega you know
they're lighter so that's never been
huge draws then France and Ghana is
newer Derrick Lewis Derrick Lewis and
then you know the rest of the guys it's
just not it's not there so I don't know
but also with the US although you make
the money off pay-per-view you know you
look at the Fox preliminary cards
there's good fights if you're a hardcore
fight fan if you're not it's not great
so they're not putting huge names on
there remember their deal runs out then
you're with Fox so they just like a fox
fox I guarantee if there's ESPN they're
loading that thing that's a new partner
yeah so who knows man what's going on
there is power low cost out that really
muscular guy yeah Wow bring him up one
more time nice pairing fighters to Yancy
Medeiros that's a phenomenal fight yeah
Rob font ascend so it's an amazing fight
mm-hmm Fantana that's he's an amazing
fighter again there's great follow
follow
are there any steroids involved or know
how he passes I have no [ __ ] clue
I've no idea it's a good fight though I
mean what else you got gin well we just
landed on the next one so you know
Rashad Evans already you retired
yeah did you know that Johny Hendricks
retired today oh he did yeah both are
retired yeah that's good tip of the hat
to both those going to how nice guys in
a sport great courage both Hall of
Famers yeah good for Johnny it was it's
tough to see man when those guys hang
around like they did and they keep
hanging around they give them these
up-and-comer [ __ ] lines that knock
their heads off just to create you know
some sort of name for the young guy good
for them but I'm done I'm retiring I'm
getting out of there
a world I've been thinking about this
long and hard for a while I'm going to
get back to my roots I'm going to start
coaching All Saints wrestling coach a
little bit of high school last year but
I'm going to make the move over to All
Saints start doing those things good for
him one thing that I saw being home last
seven months spent time with my kids not
worrying about what I need to do I
looked at my wife has said do we really
want to do this I know I'm the one who
has to do it we want to do it you want
to go through it the grind I used to be
gone for long periods of time put my
family second do those kids yeah there
we go
good for him man I love to have drinks
what else you got you all right I got
this here all right so this is actually
where I live pretty much in front of
where I live this homeless crazy
Skid Row dish it's so true though flying
kicks oh yeah this looks super
impressive some homeless guy had a
two-by-four or whatever with a nail in
it and he actually hit someone in the
face bad so that guy got jacked so this
other Good Samaritan ran over and gave
him a sidekick you can see it here this
guy is holding a piece of plywood with a
metal nail in it turns out he had just
used it in an unprovoked attack on an
innocent man walking his dog he tries to
use it again on the bystander but gets
knocked down and he would then be chased
and taken down by several other good
Samaritans oh they whooped his ass yeah
they slew him like it was a hit like
this exactly right he looks a he's been
shot 25 times holy [ __ ] the flying
kickin suit and then civilians beat him
two decks I'm flying kick house it
landed perfectly it's very like I would
have I jump higher but it doesn't matter
not dude have a nice socks
yeah they beat the [ __ ] up now I see
handcuffed there too that's when the
cops got something I think wow what a
piece of [ __ ] I do something similar but
I won't tell a story when you
one of you meet somebody who's there I
had this exact same thing I came at two
girls sitting on a wall with a 2x4 and I
was talking about fighting as usual in a
group on MADtv
it was our wrap party and I I attacked
the guy and what yes I don't know we're
talking about I did say there was a
homeless guy downtown we're at a party
he was walking toward the two girls on
the bench the girl said what are you
doing
and he goes shut up [ __ ] and he was
gonna hit her with the two-by-four and I
I hit him as hard as I could in the back
of the head kicker punter though I
punched him as hard as I could I went
home I went running up skipping and I
went do this I did I went dude did you
crack and I was standing there I think
with Phil Lamarr and a couple other
people and it was it was they've never
seen anything like that and then a guy
dropped the two boys goodbye for fell
down and I picked it up and I crashed it
it was his back and then he got up and
screamed and ran away now he was a crazy
person
yeah but I did what I had to do and then
I went back and began to talk I was a
young as a young fiery young man always
thinking about those kinds of things but
I remember I was around about two actors
and they'd never really kind of they
were so shocked I think that I'd I had
done something that violent and that
court how well how the girls react
afterwards one of them was so hot and I
was right there didn't wide but I did
speak to her [ __ ] come on sir and she
really didn't seem to mention much about
the fact that I saved her from getting
her head Cape him by a [ __ ] 2x4 that
was 23 years ago ladies and gentlemen
mm-hmm what else yeah Jim I got this
crazy ex-girlfriend broke into her
ex-boyfriends house and forced him to
have sex with her with a machete to his
face she looks crazy yeah yeah thank you
picture like no my Chet day is not
something you want to [ __ ] around with
if you got a machete
I'm gonna probably do whatever you want
or I'm gonna try to take it from you
holy film us yeah so that's running on
earthquake how would you get hard I mean
they did date so yeah I don't know for
seven years there was a seven-year long
after she finished she sat naked on the
bed brandishing the weapon at that point
the victim was able to take several
photos which he turned over to the
police can we see any of those those be
hilarious photos yeah yeah there's no
photos chin no or maybe just um take
them my chit they away from her I would
be like ah thanks man they son
same time tomorrow we leave them while
you're having sex with her and she's
holding them I check this hold on to the
disk grabber arm and just take it away
from I'm sure killer got out many of
times or maybe he's a really small dude
yeah and maybe he's turned on by it it's
still called the cops maybe the sex game
and maybe it's kid it's it's we're in
the middle of the sex game because now
she's arrested then he has to go bail
her out yeah save her yeah and he gets
her out of jail
no we're talking now now she's got a
she's got to earn the money back that he
posted for bail that's a good plan let's
get chin face triangle crazy um I just
have one more my friend married a woman
that's sweaters great my good friend
married a woman who ran for president
United States not really well okay a
couple things you should know about her
one is she well she ran we knew she 18
ran for president United States out of a
van so that would go and she was serious
there you go now don't don't
she's like Kim pay she was a lot so you
can't use text there but what's the rule
don't marry her and have kids with her
he married her have two kids with her
and then one time I I knew something was
really up because she came out to dinner
with us and she was in her pajamas she
was chewing gum and she hated her whole
meal without spitting her gum out Wow
and my god my wife my girlfriend at the
time who became oh I've said I don't
know if you noticed this but she's crazy
she she didn't spit her gum out the
whole time and the other one at the
table noticed it I didn't notice it cuz
I was just looking at it it's probably
or I was just talking to my friend she
was painful she had her whole meal
she was just curvy as all get-out she
gets my phone yeah
yeah but yeah gets my vote you'd you and
I would do this I would go I'd go you'd
be all over that and you'd go 100%
anybody but the problem was that she ate
her meal with her gum still in her bed
I'm how you do that
yeah and that's where that's and again
these should be signs to read and the
divorce didn't work out so well
poor guy yeah then it chin you want to
see what more you're good what so is it
a good one it's just the titles funny so
it's on barstool and I thought the title
is super funny so it says massive
lesbian brawl breakout at San Francisco
Pride as dozens of caribou gay men look
on in horror hit play gotta see that
this is a bunch of lesbians throwing
down a bunch of women going going at it
something that all the guys the guys are
just watching now they grab here don't
they
you jump in there and stopping it
no I have no idea what their issues are
yeah it goes on and on it gets crazy oh
damn asses are out this is a serious
fight
Jesus violence is just for men yeah dude
old is your boy be Adam ribbons
ginormous ass being future is it
possible this one yes may I ask a
question suppose that those some of
those girls are guys don't Hey look at
this that's your boy Adam ribbon Wow was
in the front page of he's got a [ __ ]
tail piece I'm either dancer bruised out
of your [ __ ] youth bang him in a
heartbeat you [ __ ] hypocrite you I'm
talking to you about it I'm talking to
you you are in GMU that was your
boyfriend while it's my boyfriend but
you would take a glove you would do what
I call - you would do what I call this
you do makes me feel good make you take
you far you take it tomorrow you're gay
joke that makes me feel sick that's a
great why he's a phenomenal body I mean
look at his ass bro you put a wig on
that guy or don't put a wig on him
and keep them in that Deegan definitely
does a man ass it's so much muscle but
from Josh dude just some Amazon I'm a
straight man bro you know this you know
this kind of well when I look at that
I'm just saying this I'm of course I'm
straight if I had to spend a lot of time
with him on a desert island and buy a
lot of time I mean a couple minutes he's
getting [ __ ] he's a beautiful man I
just think he's great I like him I just
like Adam rhythm I'm a fan
I'm surprised he hasn't done the parler
de Sydney TV gigs yet
I love me he's like this can you shoot
his body issue was amazing but being on
one of their covers is so awesome unreal
and honestly what the [ __ ] he's got a
great sense of humor that's a great shot
good for him question is was he wearing
a sock on his three-piece set I don't
know I've done nude scenes and you wear
a little hammock and there's a string
right up your [ __ ] sure they do for that
yeah and you got a little tiny rubber
band around your waist weird I did it
when I I've done it not TV yeah a movie
called oh hi I met Sarah Marshall I've
done it a couple things where I had to
wrestle a larger black man did you see
that movie on ceremony he's been off the
spoon oh I had to wrestle oh so you were
in prison sir Marsh sure was everybody I
did well but I know I know what you said
for good sir marginal and now I go wow
I've seen that one my favorite movies
jingles mine to spoof what was it called
the guy who had knocked up Sarah
Marshall and forgot to tell her about it
super bad woody you're old yeah but I
had to wrestle
I'm sorry sir module yeah I had the rest
a large black man naked basically and it
was and then he put his ass in my face
and I went hepatitis find it there's a
picture of me wrestling and I also jerk
off and they shoot large amounts of
silicone at the camera it's such a
ridiculous movie I couldn't watch I saw
it I was like it's the it's the comes on
in the silliest movie of all time
but a lot of people have seen it
looks good no that's not it I was me on
MADtv no chance this is pre psoriasis
psoriasis good looking guy in that when
my last special my hair my shirt
that's Wadi it's nice I look at myself I
go looking kid I was good-looking man is
that it chin that's it my kids are gonna
be like that you were good-looking back
then then you see me a lot more don't
think you can shave your head well yeah
yeah you think taking propecia though I
think I got it from hims I know but do
you think you go bald bald I don't know
I don't think he's gonna leave the
presidentially look eventually the thing
that ever has to understand and the the
bummer about age is that it's all going
away
no eventually you're gonna die and I'll
look back at those pictures and go I was
good-looking that's a good shot that's
when you and I went to probably my beer
beard my beer there's the men's choice
oh yeah look at thee there are women out
there that like that guy's face
that's a cool beard it is yeah alright
hey come see me yeah go see me in Tampa
July 6 and 7 then it come see me at the
Gotham comedy club in New York City one
night only Thursday July 12th and then I
got Syracuse like 13th and 14th at the
funny bone
come see me god damn it and I'm in
Spokane Washington
coming up Spokane Washington
I think it's was it 12th 13th gin Alec
hopes July July coming it's coming
why watch in July 12th through the 14th
Austin just went on sale cap city that
is August 2nd through the 4th hot there
and then we just added doused those will
go on sale super soon I'm in Dallas the
following weekend so Austin then Dallas
get you some Texas loving T fat K calm
this is a fine kid we're out